so progeny of X is the next installment
in in the in our you know look the
project the series we've had three
titles in North America so far and you
know this is a new game with a
completely new set list compared to the
previous games but the biggest kind of
difference between this game and the
previous games is that this game has
much more this is a lot more meta meta
game kind of going on and there's sort
of store and it's like a story aspect to
as well as it's more of a nice it's not
just play a song go to the next song
play that song to the next sound a lot
another difficulty play next song
there's there's actually Store
progression there's more like you know
missions that you have to fulfill that
kind of progress things and make things
in the things forward but the core
gameplay remains sort of essentially
untouched they've added another one
wincing more cup mechanic called the
rush mechanic which is basically when
you'll see these rush icons up here and
when it hits you just have to kind of
rapidly mash the button really quickly
to kind of build meter but it's still
the the project diva that everyone has
come to know and love
yes I know and I'll just out getting
that woven when I show you the gameplay
but yeah so there's more mission mode so
there's things that you'll have to
achieve to progress the story and unlock
new elements and not unlock new certain
aspects of the game Oh some of them some
of those missions which which are called
requests some of the requests are called
are simple just like clear this song but
some of them are a little bit more
texture in require you to do perform
certain songs or certain conditions with
certain modifiers so it definitely adds
a little bit more more sort of
mitigating to them to the estimating so
I'm gonna switch to a different song
here let's see what was the other one in
we can shoot
holy lives now we're in the hall so um
so so like I mention that there was a
mention that there's a story mode so
it's not really strong but the the game
progression is driven through this sort
of narrative as Miko and her friends
sort of try to restore light to the
world in this game the role is broken up
into five clouds each cloud is
represented by a specific aura that they
have to kind of explore as they as they
move through the clouds so the five RS
are classic cool cute elegant and perky
and so as they explore each cloud and
you know perform songs within those
clubs they learn what it means to be
quirky or they learn what it means to be
cool and you kind of kind of go because
there's all the songs in this particular
clouds are like cool rock songs or like
cute idol pop songs and so by performing
those songs they kind of learn how to
you know express those those particular
ARS through the aspect of exploring them
and and a lot of things stuff in the
game has been a lot of the cosmetic
stuff that was in the game previously
like their costumes and the accessories
previous games they were always just
simply cosmetic but in this game there's
much more like metagame going on where
each costume has has an R associated
with it so if you basically if you're
playing a cute song and you wear a cute
acute or outfit you'll basically kind of
apply like a multiplier to how much how
many points you drive from from from
playing the song and so because that
metagame you know if people have to kind
of think more strategically about what
sort of parts are kind of changing about
the characters and how they're
performing because if you can either
play it just whatever you want to do
however you want to but it kind of slows
down your progression it's important to
kind of consider how you're you're
putting everything putting each
performance together because if you
build optimal performances you basically
generates more voltages to sort of
in-game currency is called by generating
mobilities you push the game forward
quick
so another interesting aspect which I'm
going to record here at necks is that
we've also included a new type of song
which are medleys which are basically
like a couple songs in one they instead
of having these one-off songs we have a
number of songs kind of combined into
one here so this is the cool medley
medley is in the game are essentially
boss songs so you when you go into a
cloud for the first time you can you'll
you have to play the four bass songs and
once you've cleared the four bass songs
you'll unlock so the boss Medellin and
once you clear that medley you clear the
cloud you can move on to the next cloud
oops that's not right button that's the
Japanese button right there Dan they
always they always trip you up something
so there's a there's a rush newer the
new ones of the rush icon there
there's an ende for every box
yeah there's there's a medley for every
cloud in the game oh yeah so classic
medley cute medley cool medley elegant
medley in a quirky medley
so some of the songs the medleys have
have made appearances and other other
Miku games to date but they're usually
these are like kind of remix and since
they're combined into the music it's
like a completely different sort of
experience altogether so there are four
difficulties easy normal hard and
extreme
so another thing that so in project even
after second week they had during the
chance times if you cleared the chant
time we basically caused it a special
sort of an event to happen but in this
game they've changed the manic mechanic
into where you basically the characters
go through these transformations but but
I haven't enabled a transformation or
this but when they go for the trend
that's how that's how you obtain modules
in the previous games when you would you
basically play the games and play the
songs and you get currency and you take
the currency and you use the buy outfits
in the store but in this game instead of
a currency based system it's more of a
it's more of a it's a they change it to
a drop system so what happens is when
you clear when you clear the chance
times and you hit that big star the
characters will go through a
transformation which I'll show you show
you up here in a second and what they
transform into is sort of essentially
random but you can depending on which
which outfits you choose and which kind
of items that you equip your character
with you can influence where you're more
likely to get like a rare drop or a
common drop so there's some there's some
gamification there as well I mean it
just gives more replay value because
when you play the songs you don't know
what you're gonna you never know what
you're gonna get so it becomes this sort
of like gotcha pong a kind of mechanic
so I'm going to drop I'm gonna drop this
into the board so that what we were just
saying was basically a full unlock
version so I could access the the insert
in game stuff but what I'm gonna do
right here is I'm gonna drop into
basically this is basically like 30
minutes into the game 3040 minutes in
the game so I've we've played through
the the classic cloud the very first
college you have access to once you
clear that first cloud you have an
option to choose which cloud you want to
explore next so you can choose from any
four so it's nonlinear you can go to any
cloud and so we're gonna kind of check
out what it's like to kind of play
through essentially a single arc okay
so we've been integrated so the room
stuff in here you can actually kind of
you can kind of tap Miku right here tap
over here all right you got reacts right
and you really it's actually interesting
so you'll need this is a this is
actually me going into her classic
format you see her kind of standing here
you can actually go and change her
if you change her into a different
outfit like let's say I'm gonna put her
in a let's put her in see Lily which is
a cute you can see which which R is
associated with by the little icon there
the star lucky stars cute so I'm gonna
put her in cute and they're in her
personality will change and some of her
dialogue Ackley changes slightly
depending on what her active R is so
that kind of gets players can kind of it
kind of feel like what is cute Lika like
where does quirky need to like so like
here if I tap rienne see I was like a
different sort of a different reaction
wherever I am so we're gonna go go into
cloud that's this cloud request is the
is the new thing so here we are we can
choose any cloud you want to go to being
a clue cute cute cloud cool cloud
elegant cloud or the quirky cloud so
we're gonna jump in here try quirky
exactly as you're all the songs so first
of all you can you can of course you can
start with any song you want so we can
go and jump in here and pick any song we
want to play what's a good quirky song
let's start at this one look like and
just let it play so so go back to the
gamification so one of the one of the
big things that kind of happens as you
press for the game is the ability to
generate voltage when you're playing so
right now I had since I'm I'm in the
Corki cloud but I have a cute outfit on
right a cute module on if I go in here
and I pick it's to pick a for that
hoodie fun in front of quirky oh let's
pick this one you'll notice a might
might have a voltage Rachel illness that
popped up there which means I basically
generate more more voltage through play
throughs you can actually add
accessories and different things and
different combinations which add to that
bonus and cause you to sort of generate
voltage quicker and quicker which is
very important not so much important for
the front end of the game but it becomes
very important later and for later in
the game you need the be generating
voltage to push the story forward but in
the first part of the game when you're
just initially exploring the clouds it's
just you're simply trying to get through
the songs but voltage also determines
how much voltage you chuck you get
determines how many items drop at the
end of the
the into the stage which you'll see in a
second so we're gonna let this play
through right yeah yeah so so like as
you as you get past a certain certain
point in the game you'll have to kind of
start playing songs to charge the the
cobb prisms up and the speed at which
they they're charged by generating
voltage I mean if you only generate a
little bit of voltage they don't charge
very quickly but if you charge lots of
all digits they charge very quickly and
that just the more you do it the more
voltage and more times you charge the
crystals
you know there's certain content that's
like oh you've done this or you've oh
you've collected this much voltage today
more content more are things that unlock
as you progress
so you'll see right here it's they
already I have a 20% bonus on this
season 120% down here yeah so that's a
multiplier that's being applied to every
time I every time you hit it up points
here is this it has this voltage counter
down here in the right side so the more
more multiplier I have the more points
I'm basically getting it for that and
these old ones that the little glow on
you'll notice I'm certain some notes
have have like a little glow around it
spreading the finer just wait for a
second just wait not yet you'll see what
you'll know you'll see when you see it
yes
yeah that one right there if you hit
that you get like an instant 5% boat
boost on it so that kind of thing that's
kind of added more mechanics more things
to kind of look out for I think they
were set in the same place every single
time but this depends on the pond the
difficulty as well so so by clearing is
what happens is um you'll you'll trigger
these like I said they you know there's
there's more of a story progression and
this women bred in previous games so
like once you've finished a song you're
gonna get like a little cutscene where
the characters start talking about you
know what it means to be quirky so
because we're in the quirky cloud we're
gonna have Miku and her friends learning
about what it means to be quirky
you can't show this no this is just for
you
just to kind of get an idea how with it
what the cutscenes look like in me yeah
they've never had any dialogue
characters have never had any dialogue
or anything so this is this is actually
really really you know a challenging
aspect I think it's it like you as Misha
these are all licensed characters and
the interesting thing about about you
know Vocaloid in general is that people
they're sort of blank slates and so
people kind of project themselves on to
the characters so that so it's actually
kind of it's kind of a challenge to come
in here and try to give them interesting
personalities without if you go valve
offending anyone you know like like you
know it's it's it's a been a real
challenge but it's actually very
interesting as well I mean just there's
a lot of thought that's been gone into
it and because because at the same time
you know we had to all these you know
each character when they're in their
classic style they're kind of
straight-laced but if they're in the
quirky style they're cool style that
they have to sound quirky they have to
sound cool so you kinda have to push the
character a little bit to get it there
so it's it's been a very interesting
challenge so this is a mechanic's
introduction they're introducing gifts
here so again you can give gifts and
which affects the friendship and
friendship affects how fast you charge
voltage again so again it's all it's all
bits all all the aspects of the game
used to be very like kind of well
there's this bit here and there's this
bit here this is the here but now in
project you've X they've taken a whole
bunch of mechanics and sort of finally
melded them together so there's this
nice kind of clean your progression
through the title all feeds into on each
other so that's basically it that's the
kind of the new where it's going there's
tons of stuff that I could talk for an
hour and hour and a half about but I
don't think Johnny let me talk that long
you